[Musique]
qui seront les nouveaux seigneurs de la
villette
la chevauchée est elle achevée avec la
récente décision gouvernementale de
mettre fin à l'ensemble des activités de
la villette à compter du 15 mars 74
ainsi se terminerait la chimère esquissé
il ya 15 ans prévoyant l'aménagement
d'un complexe à l'échelle du marché
commun ratant quelques 700 mille tonnes
de viande par an le premier budget 873
millions de francs les mois et les
travaux passants la facture atteint 65,6
115 millions en 69 le conseil de paris
refuse des rallonges assuré on tente
bien alors de réorganiser une commission
de sénateurs mènent une enquête
rien n'y fait il est déjà trop tard le
tonnage a battu passe de 49 mille tonnes
en 71 à 33 milles en 73 ce n'est plus
qu'une moyenne entreprise occupant des
locaux dix fois trop grand et un
personnel trop nombreux il ne reste plus
qu'une solution arrêter l'hémorragie
une décision que nous présente monsieur
sérignan vice président de la société
d'économie mixte de la ville
la décision de suppression david est n'a
hélas rien de surprenant
puisque l'évolution économique était
hélas personne perceptible
depuis de nombreuses années et que nous
avons enregistré depuis 1971 une chute d
abattage et une récession des autres
activités telles qu à moins de mettre
dans l' équilibre de la villette des
sommes toujours plus importante
il paraissait sans espoir de maintenir
en vie un organisme qui constamment
avait besoin de nouvelles transfusion de
sang
il est évident qu'une reconversion
signifie un changement d'affectation et
un changement d'utilisation ce qui veut
dire qu'il y aura des modifications
importantes à faire compte tenu du
nouvel utilisateur et contenus bien
entendu du caractère plus ou moins
souple du bâtiment auquel on se rapporte
je donne un exemple dans les bâtiments
d'abattage les sols ont une pente
inclinée pour permettre l'écoulement des
eaux de lavage et autres produits
on sera obligé de rectifier cela par
contre il y as en dessous du bâtiment
inachevé et de la grande salle de vente
4000 places de parking 4000 places de
parking souterrain c'est évidemment un
aimant majeur une opération de
l'aménagement auquel on ne renoncera pas
un point important dominera doute cette
opération
la villette ne seront pas vendus l'état
a déjà déclaré clairement par la bouche
des ministres qui n'entendait pas
laisser se développer à la villette des
opérations spéculatives et qu'il
entendait pour réserver l'avenir sur une
zone aussi importante de paris
conservait dans le patrimoine public
les 55 hectares et maintenant avant la
fin de l'année le plan de rénovation
sera déposée avec l'immense possibilité
de ré équilibrage de la région
parisienne que représente la villette
c'est une occasion unique quant aux
zones touchées par la faim des abattoirs
ils iront en province ou à rungis non
sans penser avec amertume aux espoirs
formulés depuis 15 ans la page est
tournée
l'horloge symbolique marque un nouveau
temps pour la vigne
[Musique]